[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans ce sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur Public Sénat vous le savez
la promesse est dans le titre donner du
sens à l'actualité vous proposez des
clés de compréhension des crises que
nous traversons et justement la loi de
programmation militaire présenté ce
matin en conseil des ministres
évidemment compte des conséquences de la
guerre en Ukraine 413 milliards pour
s'adapter aux nouvelles menaces c'est un
effort inédit indispensable pour
Emmanuel Macron et beaucoup d'experts
indécent pour celles et ceux qui
comparent ces sommes au 13 milliards
nécessaires à l'équilibre de notre
régime des retraites on en débat dans
une minute et puis dans trois quarts
d'heure on se pose une question simple
faut-il renationaliser les autoroutes
une commission d'enquête sénatoriale et
un rapport de l'Inspection des finances
pointes des concessions mal négociées et
des surprofis pour les sociétés qui
légèrent figurez-vous que un rapport de
l'Inspection des finances pas des
gauchistes dit que l'État pourrait
toucher
54 milliards si on arrêtait ces
concessions
54 milliards c'est trois années de
déficit du retraite rien qu'avec les pH
les autoroutes mais l'État peut-il
mettre fin au contrat en cours sans
risquer de Lourdes pénalité un
établissement public serait-il meilleur
gestionnaire et puis le gouvernement
pouvait-il empêcher la hausse des tarifs
instaurer début février ne ratez pas
notre second débat tout à l'heure mais
d'abord donc les détails de cette hausse
massive du budget de nos armées avec
Fabien reccker
réarmer le pays dans un contexte lourd
de menace Guérande Ukraine terrorisme
campagne de déstabilisation de la France
en Afrique la loi de programmation
militaire présentée par le gouvernement
doit donner les moyens à l'armée de
répondre à ses défis est-ce que la
France saisit cette opportunité et qu'on
reste parmi les quelques nations en
capacité de se protéger seul de manière
autonome ou est-ce qu'au contraire on
décroche et on se met dans la d'autres
capitales c'est un peu comme si
l'égalises dans les années 60 avait dit
l'atome pour la diffusion nucléaire
c'est pas pour la France et là le choix
que le Président de la République a fait
c'est de nous dire à la hauteur de nos
moyens par définition il faut faire
attention l'argent public comment rester
dans le club des nations capables de se
protéger c'est une enveloppe de 413
milliards d'euros pour la période 2024
2030 contre 295 milliards sur la période
précédente un effort financier étalé
dans le temps le budget des armées
devrait augmenter de 3 à 4,3 milliards
d'euros par an à partir de 2024 de
l'argent qui doit en grande partie
servir à moderniser l'arsenal de
dissuasion nucléaire permettre la
construction du prochain porte-avion
français qui succédera au Charles de
Gaulle ou encore augmenter les moyens
alloués aux renseignements il s'agit
aussi d'adapter notre armée aux nouveaux
champs de bataille comme l'espace le
cyberespace ou la guerre
informationnelle à côté des milieux de
traditionnels la mer le terrestre
l'aérien il y a ces autres champs
nouveaux que sont le cyber espace que
sont les fonds marins notamment qui sont
l'influence à la communication et qu'il
va donc falloir se doter des moyens pour
pouvoir agir dans ces milieux là
notamment par exemple la cyberte défense
il y a des attaques régulières par
exemple contre des hôpitaux on l'avait
vu l'année dernière et bien cela
nécessite un effort supplémentaire de la
part de la France le gouvernement doit
maintenant convaincre les parlementaires
il espère pouvoir faire adopter cette
nouvelle loi de programmation militaire
d'ici le 14 juillet
pour se débat j'accueille le général de
ligue trinquant bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes ancien chef de la
mission militaire française à l'ONU
Sylvie mathélie bonsoir et bienvenue
économiste directrice adjointe de
l'Institut de relations internationales
stratégiques Pierre Laurent bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
sénateur communiste de Paris
vice-président de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées Émilie zapalski bonsoir
Émilie bienvenue à vous spécialiste en
communication politique et éditorialiste
pour sens publique on rappelle ce
chiffre qui va animer évidemment ce
débattre 113 milliards d'euros la loi de
programmation militaire d'ici 2030
Gérald trinquant de mémoire de militaire
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu un
téléphone
alors en chiffres non mais je rappelle
qu'avant les années 90 en relativement
au PIB c'était 3,5 points de PIB à
l'époque nous avions les forces du pack
de Varsovie qui était à une étape du
Tour de France
et donc l'effort était important c'était
une armée de conscription aussi et le
nucléaire était là donc toute proportion
gardée aujourd'hui cet effort par
rapport à la dégringolade des 20 années
précédentes c'est absolument remarquable
ça va être un doublement du budget de la
défense j'aurais pu poser la question
différemment est-ce que vous avez déjà
vu un rattrapage entre guillemets aussi
rapide non alors vous avez raison là en
revanche vous avez parfaitement raison
avant il y avait une continuité parce
que la menace était là ensuite il y a
une dégringolade les fameux dividendes
de la paix et il y a six ans simplement
que la France remonte la pente en
réparant les armées et le but c'est de
les moderniser maintenant et de les
mettre vraiment à hauteur des enjeux il
faut reconnaître qu'en plus c'était pas
le cas il y a 6 ans mais en plus il y a
la guerre en Ukraine qui naturellement
sensibilise tout le monde au grand
changement géostratégique en cours
Sylvie matériaux militaire elle
correspond évidemment à une nouvelle
donne des relations internationales
tiens aujourd'hui la Finlande qui qui
entre qui adhère à l'OTAN enfin on
aurait eu du mal à imaginer ça peut-être
qu'il y a quelques années alors une
nouvelle donne des relations
internationales qui qui a commencé il y
a déjà plusieurs années et c'est vrai
que la guerre en Ukraine a peut-être
réveillé des Européens qui on va dire
les lois de programmation ont cessé en
fait de revoir à la baisse les dépenses
militaires dès 2001 donc les attentats
du 11 septembre et je crois que c'est à
ce moment-là qu'on se rend compte que le
monde est en train de changer mais c'est
vrai que les européens bénéficient d'un
environnement qui est relativement
stable relativement protégé vous
interrogiez avant la guerre en Ukraine
les Allemands sur quelle était la menace
majeure il vous répondait le changement
climatique en fait il ne voyait pas de
menaces militaire donc il y a une prise
de conscience ce dont il faut bien se
rendre compte c'est que le rattrapage
est massif parce qu'on est parce qu'on
est dans un monde où depuis une
quinzaine d'années on observe une course
aux armements d'observe une accélération
de la dépense militaire partout dans le
monde sauf en Europe jusqu'à très
récemment donc vous dites quoi l'Europe
avait pas le choix
je sais pas si l'Europe avait pas le
choix parce que la dépense militaire et
la défense c'est un choix politique
c'est un choix société aussi ce qui est
certain c'est que vous avez des périodes
on a parlé à l'instant des dividendes de
la paix vous avez des périodes ou le les
tensions géopolitiques s'apaisent et où
on est dans une logique plutôt de
réduction des dépenses militaires et on
privilégie d'autres investissements
quand vous êtes dans des périodes de
tension si vous voulez suivre le rythme
et rester à la hauteur face à ces
tensions c'est ce qu'a affirmé le
président de la République et bien vous
êtes toujours engagé dans une course à
l'armement parce que quand vous
augmentez vos dépenses vos adversaires
vont faire pareil pour rester à
l'équilibre avec vous et vice versa donc
on est dans cette logique et on
s'aperçoit depuis une vingtaine d'années
que cette course aux armements elle est
engagée partout elle était peut-être pas
pas véritablement engagé en Europe et
qu'on est un peu partout en Europe il y
a pas qu'en France dans cette démarche
de rattrapage pierre alors je vous pose
un peu la même question finalement
est-ce qu'on
parler de choix politique est-ce qu'on a
le choix ou est-ce que au contraire
cette loi de programmation militaire
vous elle plutôt elle vous inquiète elle
me semble surdimensionné oui elle
m'inquiète
d'abord on a toujours on a le choix oui
on a le choix de nos orientations
politiques y compris de nos orientations
politiques de défense bon les
augmentations qui sont prévues quand
même vont conduire à dans quelques
années à augmenter de plus de 4
milliards par an le budget militaire on
est à peu près à 45 milliards
aujourd'hui on va monter à 70 milliards
quasiment en 2030
il faut que la société accepte tout ça
dans un moment où les autres ont besoin
sont loin de diminuer quand même les
besoins sociaux on en parle beaucoup en
ce moment des besoins de transition
climatique les besoins de
réindustrialisation de la France il y a
beaucoup de choses sur le les il y a
beaucoup de choses qui qui est donc
est-ce qu'il faut que vous auriez pas
forcément fait ce choix et aussi vous
étiez aux manettes vous auriez pas
forcément
parce que on nous dit bon le monde se
sur arme alors nous on va sur armée en
gros voilà la tonalité générale du débat
moi j'ai envie de questionner tout ça
parce que est-ce que la bonne réponse ou
sur un moment actuel c'est de nous de
d'y participer aussi à notre mesure
alors il y a des besoins de requipement
des armées françaises mais puisqu'on
parlait de de des années avant 90 mais
on n'est pas en train de construire du
tout la même armée que celle qu'on avait
à l'époque heureusement d'ailleurs
heureusement
on avait une armée
une armée de conscription tournée
essentiellement vers la défense du
territoire national aujourd'hui on a une
armée qui se prépare à participer à
toutes les guerres menées par les armées
occidentales à travers le monde
est-ce que c'est le bon choix pour
préparer la paix où est-ce qu'il faut
accepter maintenant de vivre
éternellement dans un monde de guerre et
de participer à cette à cette escalade
parce que ils ont participé à l'escalade
j'entends bien je vous donne la parole
dans un sang Émilie vous vient
intervenir moi je comprends les idées de
moderniser parce qu'on voit bien et on
l'entend qu'il y a la cyberf défense la
cybersécurité on voit qu'il y a des
moyens qui sont complètement nouveaux et
probablement on est en retard simplement
ça crée un espèce de mécanisme de on se
replie sur soi-même parce que vous le
dites chacun en fait s'arme petit à
petit on entend moins la politique
européenne de la défense et c'est un
petit peu chaque État qui commence à se
protéger parce que le monde autour de
lui est très différent au niveau
géopolitique les pois sont pas les mêmes
et on a l'impression post covid c'était
la même chose sur le plan économique et
là tout d'un coup après l'Ukraine sur le
plan militaire on a l'impression de de
nationalisme un peu c'est à dire qu'on
revient un petit peu sur soi-même on se
réarme pour se préparer à tout et moi je
questionne est-ce que c'est pas au
niveau européen davantage d'organiser ça
puisque on voit que le poids il est
plutôt au niveau européen dans des
guerres comme ça est-ce que tout seul on
peut faire le poids là-dessus et est-ce
que c'est bien de mettre le paquet oui
de moderniser mais de mettre le paquet
en pensant que seul on peut s'en sortir
je suis pas sûr mais je pense que vous
avez raison de dire qu'on n'est pas dans
un situation que avant 90 et donc on n'a
pas du tout les mêmes objectifs je
rappelle qu'en 90 encore une fois une
étape du Tour de France donc moi j'étais
en Allemagne à l'époque on avait les
obus embarqués et on était prêt à
combattre tout de suite là on est plus
du tout la menace en Ukraine elle est
quand même loin de nos frontières donc
la loi de programmation elle est trois
volets très distincts première point
protection de la population française
c'est quoi c'est la diffusion nucléaire
je rappelle que la dissuasion nucléaire
c'est pas fait pour faire la guerre
c'est fait pour empêcher que la guerre
ça c'est le premier point deuxième point
la France n'est pas comme l'Ukraine et
n'est pas comme un autre pays j'ai été
aux Nations Unies vous l'avez souligné
aux Nations Unies vous voyez que la
France elle est présente dans le
Pacifique de aux Antilles elle est dans
l'océan Indien elle est présente
outre-mer et ça c'est la loi de
programmation militaire mais l'accent
là-dessus bien sûr bien sûr et ça c'est
un volet qui a souvent été oublié et
donc il faut compter sur tous ces
territoires qui font que la France n'est
pas comme un autre pays elle est
présente un peu partout et le troisième
volet alors je reviens à votre volet sur
l'Europe la France a un créneau mais un
rôle à tenir dans cette défense
européenne et c'est là où les arbitrages
entre l'Armée de l'Air la marine et
l'armée de terre sont ont été faits
c'est que l'armée de terre oui va tenir
son rôle au sein de l'Europe en
fournissant par des moyens d'être très
techniques mais une div blindé avec un
été majeur de corps d'armée c'est la
place qu'elle doit tenir mais pas plus
parce que là-dedans elle tient un rôle
comme les autres Européens mais pas
comme les auto européens c'est une
puissance mondiale et dotée de l'arme
nucléaire je rappelle qu'en Europe on
est les seuls à l'avoir et qu'on est les
seuls aussi à voir c'était retard
outre-mer je pense allez-y excusez-moi
je pense qu'il faut pousser on peut le
débat on veut faire la guerre où et
contre qui concrètement ce que vous nous
parlez de l'outre-mer etc on a une
présence on va dans l'océan Indien dans
en Polynésie dans le Sud-Est asiatique
si nous allons aller faire la guerre et
la guerre contre qui si tu veux aller
faire la guerre si tu veux la paix
prépare la guerre c'est pas quand la
guerre arrive qu'il faut s'y préparer il
faut s'y préparer avant ça s'appelle la
dissuasion non mais la dissuasion c'est
une chose là on est en train et de
garder la dissuasion et de faire monter
nos armées conventionnelles en haute
intensité pour aller participer je
rappelle que la diffusion n'est pas que
nucléaire mais pour aller participer à
des guerres non la dissuasion n'est pas
que nucléaire
donc moi je dis par exemple puisque vous
citez l'outre-mer est-ce que quelle est
la politique de la France pour créer de
la sécurité régionale durable dans ces
régions est-ce que notre le renforcement
de nos moyens militaires dans ces
régions c'est le moyen de créer de la
sécurité régionale dans ces régions nous
nous sortons d'une période où nous avons
fait beaucoup d'interventions militaires
en Afrique on peut pas dire que les
résultats en matière de sécurité ont été
fantastiques alors celui qui porte cette
loi de programmation militaire
évidemment c'est le Ministre Sébastien
lecornion on écoute ce matin à la sortie
du Conseil des ministres je pense que
désormais les élites françaises y
compris politiques vont aussi séparer
entre deux camps celles et ceux qui
considèrent que les menaces sont réelles
concrètes durables et celles et au fond
qui n'y croient pas et ça je suis très
frappé ça parce que au sein même de
certaines formations politiques on a des
gens qui sont dans une approche très
différente en disant au fond on a la
diffusion nucléaire on pourquoi mettre
plus d'argent sur cette affaire là sauf
que lorsque je le décline est-ce qu'on
est complètement défendu sur le cyber de
demain la réponse est non est-ce qu'on
est complètement défendu dans le spatial
la réponse est non est-ce que notre
défense solaire est suffisante à moitié
donc en fait quand je repars et que je
repars des objets militaires réels je
suis capable de vous certifier droit
dans les yeux qu'à 413 milliards d'euros
il y a rien de trop il y a rien de trop
avec 413 milliards d'euros on reviendra
sur les nouvelles menaces parce que
c'est un aspect qui est vraiment
intéressant
sur les deux camps je sais pas si vous
avez bien entendu ce que disait
Sébastien Lecornu dit
ce qui considère les menaces réelles
concrètes durables puis ceux qui au fond
n'y croient pas et qui disent avec la
décision nucléaire on s'en fiche vous
mettez dans l'un ou l'autre
on s'en fiche d'abord il y a pas deux
camps dans le monde aujourd'hui le monde
est un peu plus compliqué que ça ça ne
s'amplifie pas les choses les menaces
sont plus diversifiées que ça mais je
note quand même parce que le débat
stratégique a été beaucoup escamoté
puisqu'on n'a pas eu de débat réel au
Parlement sur la revue nationale
stratégique pas plus qu'on a eu le livre
blanc avant d'aborder le débat
budgétaire de la LPM contrairement à la
précédente loi de programmation long
terme
le ministre puisque évidemment je j'en
parle dans les auditions avec lui dit
toujours les menaces mais lesquels
parlons concrètement de contre qui nous
voulons diriger nous diriger avec quels
alliances ou pas de quelle manière etc
tous ces débats stratégiques pour le
moment sont escamotés on nous assène en
permanence l'argument
la guerre menace et c'est vrai puisqu'on
voit des états agressifs plus qu'avant
donc nous allons nous sur armer donc ça
nous serons protégés moi je questionne
ce raisonnement dans l'ordre
cinématellit d'abord et puis ensuite le
général trinquant sur ces nouvelles
menaces elles sont elles sont enfin
elles ont été en partie listées dans le
sujet qu'on a fait en ouverture là aussi
il y a des arbitrages à faire des choix
à faire mais est-ce que c'est vrai
qu'elles sont plus nombreuses
qu'auparavant alors elles sont
nombreuses c'est certain et surtout
elles bonne nouvelle et c'est toute la
difficulté en fait avec le le budget
militaire déjà vous l'avez ça a été
répété vous avez la position de la
France la France est une grande
puissance ou veut se veut comme une
grande puissance ça aussi c'est un choix
c'est un choix politique c'est un choix
sociétal le choix qui a été fait
aujourd'hui c'est notre siège permanent
au Conseil de sécurité donc il faut
assumer avec une posture de défense qui
est à la hauteur ça c'est un premier
élément vous avez ensuite ces menaces
qui ont changé c'est à dire pendant des
années on s'est préparé à des opérations
extérieures à une armée expéditionnaire
là où la guerre en Ukraine finalement
nous ramène à l'idée que peut-être un
jour dans un proche avenir on pourrait
être engagé dans un conflit de votre
intensité peut-être à identifier je suis
d'accord avec vous c'est peut-être une
menace crédible en tout cas on l'a
assumé comme tel et pour cela il faut
investir il a été décidé qu'il fallait
investir plus massivement pour renforcer
nos forces pour être en capacité
d'intervenir dans cette intensité on est
aussi et nos industriels de la défense
sont aujourd'hui confrontés à une double
révolution qui nécessite des
investissements c'est la révolution
digitale d'une part avec les cyber
menaces mais aussi le le digital pour
pour armer et pour s'armer et pour faire
évoluer nos armements et puis c'est là
c'est la transition énergétique on sait
que des grandes entreprises de la
défense des motoristes ou de
l'aérospatiale sont en train de
réfléchir aux moteurs de demain comment
demain on assure une armée qui est
neutre en carbone qui émet moins de CO2
etc donc c'est vrai que on est à un
moment donné ou outre les menaces la
guerre en Ukraine qui repositionne les
missions de nos armées au début des
années dans les années 90 on parlait aux
États-Unis de révolution des affaires
militaires là aujourd'hui on nous parle
de transformation de ce que j'ai vu de
la loi de programmation militaire on est
à peu près au même moment c'est-à-dire
on change de paradigme avec des menaces
différentes est-ce qu'elles sont plus
importantes ou pas j'en sais rien en
tout cas elles sont différentes donc il
faut s'armer différemment et puis cette
évolution de ces évolutions
technologiques
où cette évolution environnementale qui
oblige à investir vers de nouveaux
armements donc c'est la conjonction de
tout ça la posture de la France et de
tous ces événements qui font que on
décide d'augmenter aussi massivement les
le budget militaire les nouvelles
menaces lesquelles vous semblent vous
les les les les mieux adressés par cette
loi programmation on en a parlé le cyber
ça c'est le cyber le cyber la menace
elle est de tout temps donc il y a une
menace cyber le satellite l'espace
l'espace était pas un espace de menace
militaire
on ne vit que par
l'informatique et les satellites les
câbles sous-marins on a bien montré la
fragilité de ces systèmes qui reposent
les communications qui passent par les
câbles sous-marins voilà trois menaces
que j'ai des j'ai décrite lesquels il
faut qu'on s'équipe les drones j'entends
les ce matin d'ailleurs c'était c'était
toujours sur RTL le mini armée parlait
de de menaces éventuelles pendant les
Jeux Olympiques avec des drones civils
qui peuvent être détournés donc ça ça
fait drone alors les drones de de
d'abord se servir des drones les armées
n'en avaient pas assez il y en auront
bientôt 3000 parce qu'ils ont besoin au
niveau tactique de drones pour avoir
vraiment un une évaluation et une
capacité d'attaque mais aussi la
neutralisation des drones c'est-à-dire
repérer les drones et être capable de
les neutraliser vous avez raison en
citant les Jeux Olympiques par exemple
et la menace qui pourrait y avoir sur
ces drones donc voilà quelques menaces
nouvelles dont on ne parlait pas il y a
10 ans et dont aujourd'hui il faut
s'équiper et dans la loi de
programmation il y a un effort très net
qui est fait sur ces moyens là et
l'artillerie solaire par exemple la
défense anti-aérienne avait été j'allais
dire un peu oublié parce que
effectivement dans dans les opérations
qui avaient lieu en Afrique en
particulier et pas de menaces aérienne
donc évidemment il y avait pas de moyens
et rien mais je reviens aux dividendes
de la paix on a réussi à gagner garder
une armée échantillonnaire c'est-à-dire
un petit échantillon de chaque des chars
de l'artillerie de l'artillerie solaire
etc et ça a été la chance de la France
parce qu'aujourd'hui elle peut
reconstruire là-dessus et reconstruire
avec des volumes peut-être plus
importants mais donc je reviens sur ces
menaces il y a beaucoup de menaces
nouvelles et c'est sur celle-là que qui
est donné l'effort dans le futur loi de
programmation alors on va continuer à
parler évidemment et je propose à
Quentin calmer de nous rejoindre tout de
suite sur ce plateau puisqu'on va on va
voir bonsoir Quentin un soir de
programmation militaire a été reçu au
Sénat alors plutôt favorablement à
l'exception des communistes on entend
qui font entendre un message singulier
mais au Sénat c'est vrai qu'on milite en
faveur de ces Hauses de budget depuis
plusieurs années et donc la perspective
de voir 413 milliards d'euros de budget
sur la période 2024 2030 ça satisfait
notamment les sénateurs LR on a posé la
question à Cédric Perrin qui est
vice-président de la commission des
affaires étrangères et des forces armées
ici au Sénat écouter le
donc c'est un effort important
évidemment mais je rappelle quand même
que la période nécessite un effort
important et ceux qui espérait en tout
cas un saut quantitatif important à
l'air de la nouvelle compétition des
puissances à l'échelle mondiale en
seront un peu seront un peu déçus à la
sénateur Cédric Perrin qui avait rédigé
un rapport au moment des un an de la
guerre en Ukraine on avait déjà parlé
dans cette émission d'ailleurs on
l'avait reçu en février dernier avec
Jean-Marc deschini ils avaient pointé et
bien ce que devrait être les priorités
de la loi de programmation militaire on
a retenu quelques priorités à l'époque
la prochaine LPM écrivait-il doit
consolider nos défenses solaires et nos
moyens de lutte antidrone vous en
parliez à l'instant les programmes
concernant le futur du combat terrestre
et de l'artillerie doivent être lancés
la politique des stocks doit être aussi
revue on en parlait aussi sur les
munitions etc les moyens enfin
d'évacuation sanitaire le maintien en
conditions opérationnelles la logistique
sont des points majeurs à haute
intensité potentiellement blo quant et
les systèmes là aussi une remontée en
puissance des moyens alors dans le
détail que dire de la trajectoire
annoncée ce matin en conseil des
ministres vu en tout ce que les
sénateurs avaient proposé dans leur
rapport écouter un nouveau Cédric Perrin
écoutez moi très honnêtement pour
l'instant j'attends d'avoir le détail
très très pointu de ce qui sera dans la
LPM les travaux vont commencer les
travaux parlementaires vont commencer ce
qui est certain c'est qu'il y a un
certain nombre d'abandon qui me semble
préjudiciable notamment sur le tour-afal
que le Président de la République je le
rappelle avait annoncé lors de son
discours à Mont-de-Marsan en le 19 je
crois janvier dernier moi j'attends
vraiment d'avoir un détail très complet
de ce qui sera fait et ce qui ne sera
pas fait voilà on verra le détail des 36
articles de cette loi de programmation
militaire les sénateurs disent qu'il
faudrait voir comment sont financés et
comment sont fléchés les financements le
ministre a précisé simplement pour
l'heure et on va le voir dans une
interview au Parisien qu'il y avait des
sauts technologiques spectaculaires qui
sont de plus en plus brutaux et donc
coûteux et il a listé l'espace les fonds
marins le cyber là encore vous en parler
il y a un instant Thomas comme des lieux
nouveaux de conflictualité et de
militarisation et bien à gauche au Sénat
on salue cette prise de conscience
écoutez Rachid temal alors socialiste il
était sur notre plateau ce matin d'abord
maintenir les capacités à français c'est
important mais il faut aussi imaginer
les armes de demain parce que nos
ennemis continuent à se développer il y
a la guerre officielle qu'on connaît sur
Internet d'opérations mais comme la
diniste il y a plein d'autres défis
qu'on ne voit pas au quotidien et donc
moi je crois qu'il est important
effectivement notre pays soit doté voilà
on a entendu les LR on entend les
socialistes on le voit il y a une un
accueil positif sur ce texte on refuse
toute approche politicienne on l'entend
donc à la gauche comme à la droite c'est
pas le même son cloche à l'Assemblée
nationale Thomas ou certains LR ont déjà
dit qu'ils ne voteront pas cette loi de
programmation militaire alors on verra
en séance ça commence à se jouer les
députés examineront la LPM mi-mait les
sénateurs mi-juin pour une promulgation
autour du 14 juillet à 10 Sébastien le
Cornus ce matin merci beaucoup Quentin
Pierre Laurent je reviens sur les
nouvelles menaces parce que est-ce que
finalement c'est c'est incompatible avec
ce que vous
nous avons un bon problème et on ferait
même pas inventer en deux ans un géant
du numérique vous voyez ce que je veux
dire peut-on rattraper ce retard est-ce
qu'on va moi je crois que puisqu'on
parle d'investissement massif je pense
que des investissements massifs
industriels pour construire de la
souveraineté numérique française et
européenne en matière de numérique nous
protégerait bien mieux contre la menace
cyber que quelques investissements
militaires qui vont chercher à parler
les coûts parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a
des attaques cyber et il y en a
aujourd'hui et elles sont dangereuses
parce qu'elles peuvent mettre en cause
notre sécurité mais nous sommes très
dépendants la matière donc un des
critères de jugement qui sera le nôtre
aussi c'est la capacité coron ou non les
efforts proposés à construire
véritablement de la souveraineté et une
coopération en Europe qui ne soit pas
systématiquement sous la tutelle des
Américains parce que là elle aurait
armement en Europe il faut quand même
dire les choses le grand bénéficiaire du
réarmement européen engagé actuellement
c'est les américain et ça tout le monde
le dit et les chiffres
votre avis là dessus sur le la capacité
parce qu'il y a aussi un enjeu de d'un
de réindustrialisation de relocalisation
avec une telle loi de programmation
militaire on va peut-être en reparler un
peu mais sur la question du numérique
est-ce qu'il y a encore une une porte
d'entrée pour réussir à sein inventer se
créer une souveraineté numérique alors
notamment en matière militaire très
clairement et d'ailleurs la Commission
est relativement sur cette ligne et pas
uniquement pour des questions de pour
des questions militaires la question de
la souveraineté dépasse largement ce
champ là seulement c'est vrai que bah au
niveau européen on en parlait tout à
l'heure on n'est pas tous sur la même
ligne et quand on quand la commission
porte des mesures des initiatives qui
devraient permettre de financer des
projets européens de l'industrie
européenne dans le domaine de la défense
nous français on fonce et on applaudit
voir on dit c'est pas suffisant faut
aller plus loin là où il y a un certain
nombre de partenaires qui pour des
raisons liées à leur proximité et à leur
dépendance vis-à-vis des États-Unis et
de l'OTAN on pense au pays d'Europe de
l'Est par exemple et la volonté de ne
pas fâcher l'Allier américain parce que
la Russie est très très proche mais
aussi pour des raisons de parce qu'ils
sont aujourd'hui extrêmement en retard
dans leur armement dans leur industrie
d'armement dans leur capacité de
production de défense et de production
de technologie de défense qui se disent
mais au fond on n'a pas le temps on n'a
pas le temps de développer ça et il faut
qu'on achète tout de suite donc on
achète sur étagère d'ailleurs on achète
plus uniquement aux Américains parce que
ça suffit presque plus on achète à la
Corée du Sud on achète à d'autres
d'autres pays donc on se trouve dans
cette situation un peu compliquée où
c'est vrai que nous français on a
tendance à voir assez loin à préparer
demain et après-demain les la Commission
européenne les institutions européennes
sont un petit peu sur la même ligne en
tout cas en matière d'industrie de
défense nos alliés européens sont plus
dans l'urgence et dans la crainte que
demain la Russie soit à leur porte en
fait alors la question de l'urgence
justement est-ce qu'il y a urgence à
donner plus de moyens
à nos armées c'est ce que disait le
député européen elle est à
François-Xavier Bellamy ce matin il
était sur France Info écoutez
aujourd'hui comme vous le savez si on a
besoin de cette augmentation budgétaire
c'est parce qu'on est dans une situation
absolument précaire du point de vue de
nos stocks s'il fallait aujourd'hui
rentrer en guerre on aurait tout au plus
quelques dizaines de pièces d'artillerie
disponibles là où en réalité la Pologne
elle-même est en train d'en commander
plusieurs centaines ça veut dire qu'on a
été beaucoup trop paresseux au cours des
dernières années en décidant de
sous-investir alors j'ai un train on
entend beaucoup de choses là-dessus quel
serait le l'autonomie d'une armée
française projetée dans une guerre à
haute intensité ça dépend si ça se passe
sur notre sol ou si ça se passe beaucoup
plus loin c'est comme je le disais tout
à l'heure la France n'est pas l'Ukraine
la France si elle a peur la guerre
contre
je veux des usines qui maintenant
produisent 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur
7 aujourd'hui deuxièmement pour
rapatrier sur le territoire national
parce que tenez-vous bien on a découvert
dans cette audition j'ai découvert que
il y avait des sous-ensembles qui ne
pouvaient pas être fabriqué en France ou
en Europe parce que les lois écologiques
interdisaient de fabriquer par exemple
les amorces de munitions sur le
territoire parce que c'est quand
cérigène bon ben il y a un certain
nombre de choses qu'il faut changer je
crois que les mesures ont été prises
alors l'Union européenne a décidé dans
le domaine des munitions et ça s'est
tourné vers l'Ukraine naturellement de
mettre 2 milliards sur la table pour
produire un million d'obus pour la fin
du mois de mai donc la fin du mois de
mai c'est dans moins de deux mois donc
on peut pas dire que on n'est pas
capable de réagir au passage je souligne
simplement que depuis le début de la
guerre depuis un an
l'Union européenne nous étonne tous les
jours avec des capacités la facilité
européenne de paix qui était des
discussions qui n'en finissaient pas
depuis des mois sur la fourniture
d'armement létale s'arrêtait était réglé
en 48 heures donc et une accélération
comme d'habitude les crises sont des
accélérateurs et c'est sans doute parce
que l'Allemagne a très clairement changé
de stratégie quoi il faut il faut le
dire pas que l'Allemagne mais notamment
l'Allemagne alors on va parler de du
poids ou du de l'impact politique du
risque politique lié à une telle annonce
Émilie contexte social oblige évidemment
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que le climat
social est plus que tendu en ce moment
avec une population des syndicats des
oppositions qui sont très remontés
contre la réforme des retraites et donc
ça rend l'annonce du budget militaire un
petit peu délicate comment faire passer
cette augmentation on le disait tout à
l'heure 3 à 4 milliards d'euros de plus
chaque année pour les armées quand on
cherche à économiser très pauvres petits
milliards d'euros par an pour les
retraites en faisant travailler les
Français deux ans de plus alors qu'ils
ne le veulent pas d'ailleurs au sein du
gouvernement les avis divergent sur le
sujet alors justement on va parler de
ces arbitrages qui est pour qui est
contre alors on connaît le penchant
d'Emmanuel Macron pour son rôle de chef
de guerre qui lui a particulièrement
réussi lors de la présidentielle 2022 on
connaît aussi ses objectifs de
croissance et industriels de créer de
l'activité économique il a d'ailleurs
reçu le 28 mars dernier 9 grands patrons
du secteur pour se lancer dans une
économie de guerre alors il faut
traduire produire plus vite à moindre
coût d'ailleurs les industriels
n'étaient pas très enthousiastes et au
ministère des armées forcément les feux
sont plus couverts pour doubler le
budget des armées donc à Matignon et un
son de cloche un peu différent alors oui
la première ministre elle souhaitait
réduire le montant global de l'enveloppe
le mettre à en dessous de 400 milliards
d'euros et alors comme elle a vu que
l'arbitrage était en salle des faveur
elle a plaidé ensuite pour une
augmentation annuelle qui serait un peu
plus contenu jusqu'à la fin du
quinquennat donc en gros qu'on soit pas
sur les trois quatre milliards qu'on
soit un petit peu en dessous et puis
après qu'on augmente peine perdue
finalement c'est plus de 3 milliards
d'euros dès 2024 après on passe à une
pointe à plus de 4 milliards d'euros à
partir de 2028 et encore le budget
aurait été plus élevé si on y avait
intégré ce qui n'est pas le cas le
service national universel qui était qui
devrait être rendu obligatoire soit de
Emmanuel Macron bon ça a pas été ça a
été repoussé à cause des retraites c'est
pas le meilleur moyen pour pour calmer
la jeunesse on va dire alors c'est pas
simple pour Elizabeth borne qui a déjà
une mission compliquée de trouver des
alliances sur les retraites et les
futurs lois c'est difficile de
superposer toutes ces réformes et les
budgets qui vont avec et ça serait
percute aussi sur la communication des
ministres on l'a vu ce week-end c'était
compliqué pour Sébastien Lecornu le
ministre de vendre un petit peu cette
bonne nouvelle pourtant pour les
militaires le ministre des Armées il
s'est largement fait voler la vedette
par Gérald Darmanin dans la presse qui
était très remontée contre le terrorisme
intellectuel de l'extrême gauche donc là
on était plutôt sur le dossier de et
aussi par une Marlène Schiappa
légèrement dénudée dans Playboy on en a
entendu beaucoup parler alors pour
assurer le ministre on peut lui dire que
les Français sont quand même très
favorables à l'augmentation du budget
des armées en tout cas c'est comme ça
qui se positionnait l'an dernier je
pense que c'est à peu près pareil en
grande majorité oui Français sur 10 sont
plutôt pour l'augmentation du budget des
armées on comprend pourquoi alors pour
une fois que le gouvernement suit la vie
de sa population que demander de plus
Pierre Laurent est-ce que cette
comparaison la 4113 milliards d'un côté
la loi de programmation militaire 13
milliards de d'économies pour équilibrer
le régime de retard est-ce que c'est pas
un peu facile un peu démagogique à faire
de toute façon la question dans le pays
les gens vont se la poser ça on peut
faire tous les toutes les théories du
monde les gens vont se poser cette
question là je pense que les gens
n'osent pas forcément les deux parce
qu'ils ne sont pas ils sont pas
irresponsables les gens ils
réfléchissent à tout ça on prend souvent
toujours les gens un peu trop pour des
imbéciles alors qu'en fait il
réfléchissent beaucoup contrairement à
ce qu'on dit je pense que les gens par
contre se posent une question comment se
fait-il que nous pouvons faire une loi
de programmation militaire de 413
milliards on garantissant que nous
allons la respecter comme nous avons
garanti et que nous sommes incapables de
faire une loi de programmation pour
reconstruire le système sanitaire
français que nous sommes incapables de
faire une loi de programmation pour
l'aide publique au développement nous
avons débattu il y a deux ans de d'une
soi-disant programmation loi de
programmation de l'aide publique au
développement sauf que sa grande
caractéristique c'est qu'il y avait pas
de programmation budgétaire donc dans
cette loi il y en avait aucune donc
c'est ça qui choque les gens c'est que
si on prend l’hôpital on pourrait dire
413 milliards une question
avec des objectifs où j'ai dit que je
dis que je pouvais en discuter les
objectifs mais en tout cas on le fait
pourquoi c'est impossible dans des
domaines qui sont vitaux et j’ajoute que
c'est d'autant plus important comme
question à mes yeux que la plupart des
conflits dans le monde aujourd'hui alors
on pourrait discuter de ce lieu en
Ukraine mais en tout cas de nombreux
conflits dans le monde sont provoqués
par les insécurités humaines les
insécurités alimentaires énergétiques
climatiques donc des sujets dont il faut
s'occuper parce qu'on s'occuperait
davantage de la sécurité des grandes
sécurités humaines comme le demande
d'ailleurs l'ONU très souvent on aurait
moins de guerre et moins de conflits
dans le monde donc il faudrait je répète
il faudrait quand même s'interroger
effectivement sur l'équilibre global de
nos choix de nos choix politiques
aussi dans ce débat on a commencé à
l'évoquer un tout petit peu mais de de
notre industrie finalement de guerre
général trinquant il y a aussi un
argument économique si on est dans ce
enfin cet effort de guerre il aura aussi
un impact économique sur
sur l'industrie française bien sûr et
c'était l'objet de la réunion avec le
président avec les industriels ou
est ressorti là des bruits un peu un peu
dissonant parce que l'industrie on lui
demande d'accélérer on lui demande il va
falloir accélérer donc investir
et la loi de programmation on la voit
seulement les promesses de la loi de
programmation ne pourront être tenu
qu'une fois qu'elle sera votée on peut
pas dire aujourd'hui aux industriels les
milliards sont pas encore là bien sûr
bien sûr donc on dit aux industriels
prenez un risque c'est un peu le
investisseur en attendant les milliards
quand même une entreprise c'est ça doit
savoir prendre des risques surtout que
le risque est quand même mesuré quand on
voit
l'argent qui arrive avec la LPM ça c'est
le premier point le deuxième point et là
j'en parle un peu plus en connaissance
de cause pour le traiter souvent sur le
terrain c'est l'export
il faut pas attendre uniquement des
commandes de l'armée française il y a
beaucoup à l'export le problème quand
une entreprise vous lui demandez un
autre pays vous allez me donner ben on
parlait tout à l'heure de la Corée du
Sud pourquoi la Corée du Sud réussit en
Pologne parce qu'elle dit je veux des
chars demain et elle a des charges
demain si elle demande des chars à
l'Allemagne ou à la France on lui dit
dans 20 ans donc ça peut pas marcher
donc il faut faire attention au type
d'équipement qu'on met sur étagère
j'allais dire qu'on prête parce qu'il
doit convenir à l'ensemble des gens et
pas seulement aux armées françaises or
pour l'instant beaucoup des armements
prévus par les gros industriels français
ils conviennent d'abord aux armées
françaises et pas forcément à l'export
donc il y a des investissement investir
avant que l'argent arrive et de cet état
risque à prendre et puis le deuxième
avoir des armements qui puisse avoir une
échelle beaucoup plus large en comptant
sur l'exploit puisqu'on parle du temps
long la raie relocalisation ou
réindustrialisation là aussi ça ça va
prendre du temps oui ça va prendre du
temps par contre plus important la
défense en France on a des
industrialisés énormément mais il y a
quand même quelques secteurs qui restent
extrêmement forts en France il y a
l'automobile bien évidemment il y a
l'aérospatiale aussi et l'aérospatiale
qui est directement lié à la défense et
puis l'industrie de la défense surtout
d'ailleurs surtout que ce soit le naval
le terrestre ou l'aérien donc c'est
quelque chose de nouveau françaises
fortes connues dans le monde
est presque cynique mais la guerre en
Ukraine les les canons César par exemple
c'est enfin voilà c'est aussi une
démonstration enfin c'est terrible parce
que je dis mais c'est la réalité du
marché quoi et puis c'est c'est presque
c'est presque horrible d'inverser les
choses mais c'est une réalité c'est vrai
que la réindustrialisation française
elle peut passer aussi par le réarmement
de notre pays où en tout cas par des
investissements dans cette industrie
parce qu'elle est souvent duelle cette
industrie on le voit avec l'aérospatiale
il y a du civil il y a du militaire donc
forcément quand on investit dans des
technologies et quand on a des moyens
d'investir on maintient notre industrie
je voudrais juste revenir peut-être sur
les exportations c'est intéressant les
exportations c'est un vrai sujet c'est
un sujet qui est plus compliqué qu'il
n'y paraît parce que on a jusqu'à
aujourd'hui finalement
financer nos
la faiblesse de nos dépenses militaires
en disant aux industriels maintenez vous
en exportant sauf qu'ils ont exporté
vers des régions dans lesquelles ils ont
été souvent mis en porte-à-faux en fait
parce que c'est on se souvient de la
guerre au Yémen etc donc je crois qu'il
faut aussi avoir une approche beaucoup
plus large de ce que doit être notre
politique de défense et notre politique
d'armement pour un moment donné
déterminer qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire
qu'est-ce qu'on ne veut pas faire et ça
rentre dans ce dont vous parliez c'est à
dire la sécurité la sécurité sur dans ce
monde peut pas faire même à qui on vend
nos armes etc on a été quand même
relativement ouvert certains
d'exportation parce qu'il fallait
maintenir notre industrie de défense
aussi c'est en termes d'aménagement du
territoire parce que vous le l'industrie
est importante et on voit bien quand une
base ou un régiment part dans un
territoire un peu perdu on a vu ce que
ça crée les conséquences négatives
peut-être que là ça va réamorcer aussi
quelque chose de positif pour ces
territoires qui se disent toujours un
peu oubliés PME et qui sont extrêmement
importantes on parle des grandes
sociétés mais il y a beaucoup de
sous-ensemble en fait qui sont faits par
des petites sociétés Pierre Laurent
cette cet enjeu de réindustrialisation
de relocalisation ou de veiller de
sensible oui mais je est-ce que c'est le
militaire qui doit tirer l'effort de
réindustrialisation c'est un débat en
tout cas ce qui est vrai dans le domaine
militaire il y a des il y a des domaines
notamment les munitions qu'on a beaucoup
qu'on a beaucoup abandonné et d'ailleurs
les syndicats notamment des arsenaux ont
beaucoup protesté ce contre l'abandon de
ces productions sur le terrain donc on
est dépendant et là on peut reconquérir
de la souveraineté mais après pour tout
ce qui est les nouvelles technologies
toutes les technologies de rupture etc
on est toujours dans des entreprises
duales c'est-à-dire qui à la fois
travaillent dans le signe du travail moi
je crois que ces grandes entreprises
nous avons intérêt à ce qu'elle soit
tirées par le civil et pas par le
militaire et après elle serviront à
développer des des technologies de
souveraineté dont nous aurons besoin
dans le militaire mais je pense que ça
n'est pas sans que notre industrie que
soit principalement ou beaucoup tirés
par le militaire dans un certain nombre
de domaines et sur le commerce des armes
puisque ça a été évoqué je signale que
j'ai déposé une proposition de loi pour
renforcer le contrôle parlementaire sur
le commerce des arbres parce
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un contrôle
parlementaire très insuffisant sur le
commerce des armes français et on
pourrait renforcer j'ai fait des
propositions en ce sens allez 10
secondes juste dual oui mais une fois
c'est le militaire qui tire une fois
celle-ci ville qui tire ça dépend des
circonstances l'économie voulait
exactement c'est c'est donc c'est
important de se dire c'est important de
maintenir on
vous attend sur le temps du merci
beaucoup d'avoir participé à ce débat je
vous dis évidemment à bientôt sur sur
public